the most challenging task actually we
were we have been very focused on the
distraction of existing stockpiles and
the destruction activities should have
been completed last year but it didn't
happen there were several reasons for
that technical financial another and the
destruction will continue in the coming
years but i think the progress is quite
steady i expect that in 34 years maximum
we will have only one percent of
existing stock by so far we have been
able to verify destruction of eighty-two
percent but we will reach the level of
ninety-nine percent in 34 years so
that's a very a you know a development
that we I would very much welcome I've
been director general of this
organization for three and a half years
and since I'm reelect now I'm going to
stay four and a half years more so I
hope to see this achievement in the
coming near future and the second
challenge and which is very important at
the moment is the operation the joint
mission with the United Nations in Syria
and do to you know difficult conditions
on the ground this is a country which is
in the middle of Civil War and our
experts are verifying and actually
working there and they're in very risky
conditions so they have done so far a
very you know successful very
satisfactory and very courageous fact
mission job and they when I ask them you
know those who came back whether they
would like to return they said all yes
people we are ready to go back if
necessary and they are doing an
excellent job which I am actually I am
very proud of them